Conspiracy theories particularly
about the result of the 20,
20 and 2022 elections
are still quite popular
in certain corners
of the Republican Party.
Listen a mypillow
CEO Mike Lindell insists
despite having no evidence
that the election was stolen
Carrie Lake, Mark Fincham, Gymshark
Kristina Karamo
married to personal trainer Dixon Blake.
They all lost all of know, all of the one
they were.
Every one of them was scored
with computer
and we could show you
that the majority of Americans believe
the 2020 election was not stolen.
The machines were not the problem.
The majority of Americans find that shit.
Where do you find this fact?
Who gives you that suspicion?
Who gives you them?
Well, you mention the fact
that you could be a liar.
That's not a lie.
All right.
Truth. It's a fact.
Joining us now
is that other voice you heard.
New York Times reporter
conducting the interview
with Linda Ellis said Herndon.
He's the CNN political analyst,
national politics
reporter at The New York Times.
I'm where to begin.
Yeah. What was the most illuminating?
What did that tell you?
I mean, I
we really started this process
because of how we started our podcast.
We where we were originally
at Dana Point in the RNC,
and we saw Ronna McDaniel really
come on
and really embrace Mike Lindell
and the hip hop
and the chairwoman of the RNC.
And they kept he kept popping up
with all these different
Republican events.
And he was doing
so not only
with a horde of fans around him,
but continuing
to push that election conspiracy
not just denying the results,
but actually acting like
the voting machines
had been co-opted
by globalists, by the CCP.
Others,
he popped up in that defamation lawsuit
against Fox News.
And this is
someone who has ingrained power
throughout his own business
about his own fame.
And I'm using that in terms
of advertising and Fox.
We wanted to push him on that.
We knew his beliefs,
but how was he using
those beliefs to really spread
that conspiracy?
Because as we know, election
denial was a losing issue for Republicans
in the midterms.
It was an issue
they were supposed to be moving on
from looking ahead to 20, 24.
But that cannot be possible.
As the chairwoman of the RNC
was bringing Lindell on.
And he's someone who knows
that he needs that credibility
And the interview,
the thing that stuck out
the most to me was that
he was very consciously
using his fame, using his money to gain
credibility
from the establishment corners
of the Republican Party.
And he knew that with ingrain
his conspiracy
even further,
this was an active effort for him,
not a passive one.
Okay.
You spent 3 hours with him.
Did you expect this
to be a three hour interview
when you went into this?
No, we expected it to be 45 minutes.
We had a script of questions,
but the way that he talks,
infusing every portion of his life,
infusing every mention of his book,
infusing.
We're going back
to those conspiracies over and over
to get those answers.
It required that amount of time
because you have a base.
How did you finally wrap it up?
It's like we have to open
up, wrapping it up with a couple of.
He told us nearly everything.
He told stories
about Prince in Minnesota.
He told us
kind of all of these fabulous stories
about his life
that we wanted to sift through that noise
because it's still someone
who's really using that power
to do something
that is down to dangerous to democracy.
This is not something
that I think people should really dismiss
as a pass issue.
This is something
that has taken on new life
in the Republican Party.
And that's because even among the base,
there is a sense
that they're that
that this grievance is a valid one,
that the election is another piece
of the kind of culture war
that has been stolen from them,
and that that's
what he is really playing on.
And so that's
what I thought was really important
is also important for us to pair it with.
Talking to the GOP chairwoman after that,
to come to Ronna McDaniel and say, okay,
you know what Mike Lindell is saying this
and she was not stepping away from what
she's saying,
but for people who haven't listened yet.
No problem.
I mean, she was saying that really
that the Mike
Lindell has
a place in the Republican Party.
She said that she did not
She did not agree
fully with this conspiracy,
but she also did not fully deny
fraud claims either.
This is someone
who did not take the opportunity
to step away from Lindell
when we were doing that interview
and we were really talking to her,
challenged her for her job,
and he challenged her for her job.
This just speaks to the level of fact
that conspiracy is ingrained in him
as a figure is ingrained to the party.
We were doing it to try to show
the codependent relationship
between the grassroots
version of Republicans
and the establishment.
They need each other right now.
And they both know that.
And so you both had Lindell
seeking out for it.
So Ronna
McDaniel will give him some credibility.
But you also have Ronna McDaniel,
who knows that she needs
the people who like Mike Lindell
and was not willing
to step away from them.
Their hand in hand right now, even though
they're trying to move on
from the most explicit
versions of his conspiracy.
I want to hear the print story
in the commercial.
Thank you.
On top of all of this, we should know
he's been ordered to pay $5 million
because he said someone couldn't
prove him wrong on election
fraud and the person proved them wrong.
Now he's saying you won't pay.
Absolutely. Very consistent with him.
None of the facts actually matter here.
This is someone who is trying
to push those type of conspiracy.
I said 3 hours. Wow.
I want the uncut version. Do you?
I don't know.
I said, thank you so much.